welcome back to episode 2 I just
realized I wasn't recording that makes
me feel stupid and hopefully the mic is
muted either I tend to do that a lot
basically didn't miss much
a whirlwind creeped me out as hell and I
picked up this lantern so which I can
use to let up because if it's too dark
then I will go insane as you see here my
I have my head is pounding and hands are
shaking which apparently isn't good I
like when my head is not counting mmm so
we're gonna go in here check this place
out
hell
okay so this game really wants me to
check out this chest so I'm gonna do it
right into vulgar 1839 I wish I could
ask how much you remember I don't know
if there will be anything left after I
consumed this drink
don't be afraid Daniel I can't tell you
why but no this is Houston's great try
to find comfort and strength in that
fact
there is a person you are my final
effort to put things right
God willing the name Alexander of
Brandenburg stealing motrin bitter anger
in you if not this will sound horrible
alright go to the inner sanctum find
Alexander and kill him all body is old
and weak and yours young and strong now
you should complement yourself
I like my old self he must both Daniel
and so I know if I had to analyze that
then well not much to analyze what is
this this is broken glass probably from
the drink I just drank something that
erased my memory which I thought was
necessary for some reason and I left a
note for myself telling myself that I
have to kill a man which is not very
smart if you if you want to kill someone
the new just you should hide the
evidence in my opinion and this is a
share
Oh God I just [ __ ] sounds closes door
I let him all sync up on me oh yeah
though I am moving it down come on
hold left mouse and direction
[ __ ]
and then down
[ __ ] down
it is something that you need to do
before I pull this
there we go all right did it awesome
let's continue and resolve the
fragmentation of rows lingering Nathan
mouth Turkish delight he thought just
like the ones he at the consulate in
Constantinople afternoon right got a
farmer berry gonna hold Chad come
and when is right is right now
is it inside the castle - having a
manner of speaking
come bring the lamb so that was
Alexander's being a little finally have
young boys have you don't know that Eve
I have is it connected to the what did
you call it the inner sanctum our
Suffolk my most precious charity and it
lies well beyond the refinery in fact it
lies beneath the very stone of
brennenburg all right
I guess this castle is called burning
burning them or something and I sound
like a [ __ ] and the guy we're gonna
kill sounds like an epic [ __ ] so
that's bad news for me I guess open up
the cast just I mean this is not a
castle
Naida act the creepy noises ah also
thank you very much
[ __ ] books
we read this book plans and hi very nice
book my mother used to like this to me
when there's something funny
why do
never got cockroaches hello
I'm gonna call you mr. beauty no run
from me
[ __ ] it's so disgusting oh ah oil
awesome
and apparently the same [ __ ]
paintings are on the wall which means I
don't know what that means it she talked
to do paintings are loving Oh God
print you're not supposed click on big
doors then disgusting Google appear
gotta love that sound sounds like I'm
pulling a
and everybody alright let's continue
excuse me I have a cold it's so annoying
can you do
all right
down there or up there that is the
question
oh you can run off okay this looks less
creepy laboratory door slams shut behind
him and he knew he would never again see
the old Taylor of Berkeley Square
another lone soul in London seemed
appropriate so much hmm that's pretty
nice finally I understood well I don't
like this place but this is dark I can
jump down here
Oh birthday I get blood on my face when
I do that
cockroaches and stuff
with my head doing yeah it's better now
than I used to lantern
something is creeping me out
Wow that did not give me much should be
you said more efficiently all right
let's head down [ __ ] I sat down there
huh gonna use this one all right god
Oh sharks Brian
I thought I left forget that
there should be more coop right
episode 1
and one part
uh-huh okay so I'm guessing Alexander
the guy we're gonna kill left is not see
what it said these are my third attempt
to produce artificial I don't know how
you say that Veidt a the former
compounds like the potency I need but I
sense I'm close calamine and orpiment
are a given and the cup right binds them
well this time I will attempt acquire a
GI instead of a cure for this yeah good
idea sure that work in hope it will
produce a more even solution the
experiment was unsuccessful the solution
is highly acid and proves impractical to
use to any impacted to put to any use
except a detergent what is that I don't
remember that I read that in chemistry I
think organic tissue reacts
especially violently to the solution and
it should be handled with the greatest
care I might be able to use a recipe but
I'm losing hope that I will find an
alchemy solution to my press participant
all right one what is pretty cement me
is or why did whether was a [ __ ] early
stuff in the [ __ ] in the [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] is it called I don't know about
that that's approach
I don't know about you guys but usually
when there's a fire oven there is
usually like a place you put the wood
which is pretty weird doesn't really
make any sense then again this game
doesn't really have to is there anything
more in this room we need to find oh yes
I'll take that
ahsha's take that as well thank you very
much
another little note [ __ ] I hope I'm not
sniffing too much ah chemical erect
relocation the lack of Shimla to prefer
properly vented films from my most
recent experiment has taken its toll on
many of my less stable at ingredients in
storage seems something unaffected but
many are same and the fumes I'm
difficult decide which I shall do what I
can and move them to the wines
okay that didn't tell me much what is
this I need four different chemicals to
continue all right I'm gonna try and
find the chemicals I guess they're going
to go back where we went
I'll play out
don't run into many creepy things I
don't like crazy stuff makes me scared
and rizal let's go back traveling the
dot I have to read this meant going
through Canterbury he made sure the
famous avoid their sense of you've
connected within a neglect of family I
don't get this Sela Benari a very nice
whoa mom [ __ ] was that
girl screaming let's go to the wine
cellar e that was where he's gonna move
their compounds [ __ ] yet you know I need
a key
maybe the [ __ ] has one hello anybody
there I guess I'm gonna go over down
here actually did I where did I come
from I forgot
it's my only option I think have to open
this door what the hell [ __ ] dude can
I lick it that was not very tasty
uh-huh
all right I think I need my penis to do
that but I don't want to used right now
let's set up
I don't remember if I came from upstairs
or downstairs whoa
[ __ ] wins
we got here [ __ ] teleporting stones
I don't like this let's see how much oil
oh I shouldn't use that